What is up guys? Today's video I'm going
to show you a super easy money maker
that has no requirements. All you need
is money. I'm going to be using GE
tracker and I noticed that the
malediction ward if you put it together
in a set, you make a 280k profit. So I'm
going to go ahead and test that out.
So I'm going to go ahead and try to
instant buy all the malediction shards
for 120k.
Okay, instant bought. Let's try to buy
the second one.
Um let's try 230.
And now the third one. Where is it?
There it is.
Let's try to instant buy it. Um this one
normally is harder to sell, so we'll see
if this buys. Okay, it didn't buy, so
I'm going to let this sit. I might
change the price and I will be right
back. All right, so it didn't buy for
that, so I'm going to try to instant buy
it for this.
Okay, it didn't buy for that either, so
I'll wait a little bit and then maybe
I'll change the price. So I decided I'm
going to go ahead and change the price.
I'm just going to instant buy this. I
don't want to wait. It's been like a
minute and I don't want to wait any
longer.
Cuz there's really good margins right
now, so I'll just go ahead and instant
buy it for
let's try 1,765k.
All right, it instant sold. So now
let's see. Okay, I'll collect them all.
Okay, so that's how much I bought it
for.
Um I will go ahead and put an offer for
all three of them again
just to see if they buy while I'm going
to do this next method.
All right, so one of them instant sold,
so I'm going to go ahead and show you
guys what I'm going to do with these and
how I'm going to make them into full
malediction wards. All right, this is
how you're going to get there. You're
going to pull the lever in Edgeville.
Make sure to bring your malediction
shards. I bring some sharks just in In
if I do get attacked, I can just eat and
run away. Let's take a minute portion
energy portion
and then make sure to bring a
some kind of slash weapon to cut the
web. And then also bring a teleport so
you can teleport afterwards.
All right, so go ahead and teleport
here.
Obviously, if you're bringing stuff you
don't want to lose, be careful and be
ready to log, but I'm not going to lose
anything if I die.
So, just go over here, slash the web.
And then we're you're going to be
running all the way over there to where
that smithing icon is.
So, run over here.
And I will speed this up until I get
there.
All right, once you're here, run into
the center onto this bridge.
And then go ahead and use it on the
volcanic forge.
And now you have your malediction ward.
Now, I will just run down to 30
wilderness and then I will teleport to
Edgeville and I will go ahead and sell
this. All right, so I checked my history
and I made sure to see how much money I
spent. So, I spent 2,065,996
GP.
So, as long as I sell it for it. Okay,
so that'll be Let's see how much money
we make.
So, 200
and 6K minus the 65K.
So, we made around 140K and that was
super easy. All right, I went ahead and
bought two more of them.
And I'm actually going to buy a couple
more of these and see how much I can buy
if I can see if I can instant buy a few
more.
Instant bought that, okay.
Instant bought that, sweet.
Okay, and I instant bought that. Okay,
let's see
how many more I can buy.
Sweet.
And the third one.
All right, so this one is probably the
one that's going to take the longest to
buy, but
we'll just go ahead and try to instant
buy it again real quick.
All right, sweet. So, I can I mean,
jeez, look at how easy these are buying
these are coming in.
All right, so this one's not selling
right now, so I'm not going to
So, I'm going to go ahead and do
one of these at a time.
And then I will time them and see how
long each one takes, and then we'll see
how much money I make, and we'll figure
that out. All right, guys, I have
decided I'm actually going to risk it
for the biscuit, and I'm going to go
ahead and bring all of them.
So, this is how much I will lose. So,
kind of nervous,
but let's go ahead and
set up our quick prayers.
All right, that looks good. Okay, so I'm
going to go ahead and teleport there and
get ready to log.
I don't see one. I'm just going to go
ahead and start the timer,
but I'm going to be ready to log, but I
will speed this up.
All right, I will now run to the center.
That was kind of scary. I'm super mad I
didn't bring a stamina potion, so that
took a while, but I'm going to go ahead
and put it in
and make them.
Come on, where is it?
There it is.
I would have sucked if I got PK'd
because I misclicked three times.
All right, now I will run down and
teleport back. So, I'll see you guys at
the GE. All right, I'm back at the GE
and it took just over 5 minutes to do
all this. So, I'm going to go ahead and
check the history and see how much I
bought these for and then go ahead and
sell them and do some calculations. So,
I did the math and I spent 6,158,058
GP.
So, let's go ahead and sell all three of
these. Okay, so that's like almost a
500k profit. Let's see.
Okay, so they didn't instant sell. So,
I'm just going to wait a few minutes
until it sells. Sweet, they sold and it
only took about a minute. Sometimes it
takes a little bit more. It kind of
depends because I have the price, so
everyone's buying this price right now,
so it's working out well for me. But,
sometimes you may have to wait later, so
just be careful. But, anyway, so the
amount I made 6,620,046
minus the 6,158,058
equals 461,988.
So, I made about 500k in 5 minutes of
work and that would have been less work
had I brought my stamina potions. And
also, keep in mind that I also made over
100k on my other one. So, if I would
have done all of them at the same time,
I would have been making upward of 600
to 700k in 5 minutes of work. Guys, I
hope you guys like this video. Remember
to keep in mind that I was using GE
tracker for this. If you guys want to
check out GE tracker, there's a link in
my description. Go ahead and click that
and go ahead and sign up so you can use
it. There's lots of options on sets that
you can make money, like the odium ward,
that's another thing you can use in the
in the furnace that I used. And then
there's also some other things. So,
imagine if you had this much money, you
can make 962k profit just from flipping
this. Anyways, guys, I hope you guys
like this. Please give it a thumbs up if
you found it useful or helpful, and
please subscribe to the channel if
you're new to the channel. Thanks for
watching, guys. Stay tuned for my next
video.